-First off, it's always
great to see you.
-So good to see you.
-Thank you for
playing that game.
And you taught me --
you taught me
a little acting lesson.
-There you go.
-That was it, from the best.
I loved it.
I want to talk
about "Stranger Things."
-Yeah.
-First half of Season 4,
Volume 1, premieres May 27th
on Netflix.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone's freaking out.
-Yeah.
-I'm so excited.
How would you describe
this season?
What's happening with Eleven?
-My gosh. What isn't happening
with Eleven?
I think what -- The main part
and the slogan
of this story line is,
"It's the beginning of the end."
And we really have to dig deep
into her beginning
and how she became who she is
with the people around her
and how to gain that autonomy
and become this woman
on her own.
So this story line, this season
really digs into that.
-Yeah, oh, good.
We get some answers?
-Yes, definitely
lots of answers.
-Yes. I love that, all right.
-Lots of crying,
lots of laughing.
-I read somewhere that you got
your American accent
from watching "Hannah Montana."
-I did. I did.
-That is true?
-Yes, absolutely!
-Really?
-Yeah, because I watched
"Bugsy Malone" and "Godfather"
when I was like 8.
-I love "Bugsy Malone."
-Yeah, love it.
And I -- You know, my parents
were like, you know,
watching all these movies
with me.
And I was like, "Yeah, but
'Hannah Montana' is like,
Oscar-nominating.
Like, it's so good."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Hannah Montana's" the best.
-Yeah.
-Like, the film, everything.
-Everything about it
is amazing.
And I got the American accent.
[ American accent ]
So I would always literally
just be like "Hi."
Like, you know,
"How are you, Jimmy?"
[ Normal voice ]
And then, you know.
-Do you do, like,
accents when you see them,
like,
when you watch movies?
-Yeah, I like to --
to see characters,
and then I just do the accent.
As long as I've watched it
for long enough,
I can kind of get it
to somewhat of a T.
-Like, what are you
watching now?
-"Inventing Anna."
-Yes.
[ Light laughter ]
-When -- Yeah.
So, like, I was in
the hotel lobby the other day,
and they were like "Miss Brown,
we have to run your card again."
I was like [As Anna Delvey]
"Run it again!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"It must be your system!"
And it was --
"Why do you look poor?"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Do you do any other impressions?
-[ Normal voice ] Yeah.
Winona Ryder from Season 1.
-Oh, "Stranger Things"?
-Yeah.
Noah and I like to do this one.
Noah's like, "Mom,
I'm in the Upside Down."
And she's like,
"Come on, baby, I am here.
I am coming to find you, honey."
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Winona!
I love how you did that.
Noah was just here, by the way.
He was on the show,
and he's great.
Noah -- Noah Schnapp, hi.
I know you guys
are best friends.
-Yes.
-And he was telling me
the last night of filming,
I want to say --
-Yes.
-...that you played
a pretty big prank on him.
-Yeah.
Well, he's the biggest
prankster of them all.
I, too, am pretty bad.
But he --
he goes to great extents.
So we thought as a crew
that we needed to get him back.
So it was 4:00 a.m.
We were in New Mexico.
He was on set, and it was
the last night of shooting.
So we thought,
what better way to get him
than to get him to base camp,
and we had trash bins filled
with water balloons all around,
and we turned all
the lights off at base camp.
I called him, crying.
"Noah, I'm just so upset
that, you know,
you're not here
to say good-bye to me.
Please just come back
to base camp.
I'm leaving now."
[ As Noah ] "Okay, Mill,
okay, I'll be there."
[ Normal voice ]
He gets to base camp.
I'm like, "Noah, I got you
a present," you know.
And I get him in the middle
of the car park.
And all of us,
about 20 people, raid him.
Absolutely invade him.
And it's bad.
But then he -- he got
really aggressive with it.
He got me on the floor,
Absolutely just --
I was like,
"My God, I'm a girl."
-[ Laughs ]
-Jesus!
-We have a video.
Check this out. This is real.
[ Indistinct shouting,
laughter ]
-How -- How long did that last?
[ Applause ]
How long did that last?
-I'm not kidding you,
15 minutes.
Like, it was the longest video.
It was so insane.
-Are you worried that
he's gonna get you back?
-When -- I'm always --
I literally, when I see him,
I'm like, terrified, you know?
It's like, one step at a time.
-Yeah.
-I know there's a video
you brought of you and Noah
doing the Fruit by the Foot
challenge.
-Yes.
-Now, what is that exactly?
-We were on set, really, really
bored, biding time, and thought,
"What better way
to not do school
and to race each other
with Fruit by the Foot?"
So you extend the whole
Fruit by the Foot,
and then you just --
no -- using no hands,
you have to eat it
as fast as you can.
-We have -- You brought us
this video of that.
Here's --
-I did.
-Doing the Fruit by the Foot
challenge.
-Okay, ready?
Set. Go.
[ Jimmy laughs ]
-Wait, look at you!
Is he gagging?
-Whoa!
-Yeah, he was almost vomiting.
-Look at you.
-Oh, that was awful!
-Yes!
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like the dance at the end,
the victory dance.
That's -- That's pretty good.
-Yeah, so I bring them
everywhere.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You want to challenge me?
-Yes, because I just think,
you know,
what better way to leave?
We don't see each other often.
-That's true.
-I need to teach you
something else.
You know, a few acting tips
and [Chuckles] and this.
-Fruit by the Foot challenge.
You want to challenge me.
-I do, I do.
It's gonna be great.
I'll see you then.
-I'm very competitive.
Yeah, you know that.
-Me too.
Okay, so --
-What do we do?
-So what you're going to do
is you're going to extend
the whole thing.
-Mm-hmm.
-Noah's gonna die
when he sees this.
By the way, everyone refused
to do it on set with us.
Like, Finn was like,
"Leave me alone."
Um, okay.
Then, what you're gonna do
is you're gonna take
the paper off.
-Yeah, okay.
-Okay, now somebody
in the audience
has to make sure
we're at the same length.
We don't like a cheater.
-Oh, that's interesting.
-Okay?
Put it in your mouth.
-Oh, you put it in your mouth.
-Yeah, of course you do.
Okay.
Are we at the same length?
-No.
-I'm longer, right?
-Yes.
-Now what do we do?
-Are we --
Are we good?
Three, two, one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Frantic music plays ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]
-The champion! Come on.
Millie Bobby Brown!
How did you do that?
It's so good.
-They're so good.
-That's really delicious.
Everyone, I want to
show you a clip.
[ Light laughter ]
It's still in my mouth.
Here's Millie Bobby Brown in
Season 4 of "Stranger Things."
Take a look.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Students murmur ]
-Whoop. [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh my God.
♪♪
[ Students laughing ]
-Angela!
[ Screams ]
-What the hell was that?
[ Laughter ]
-Millie Bobby Brown!
Season 4 of "Stranger Things"
premieres May 27th on Netflix.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show." Stick around.